[Music]
yeah sure he's played the game a certain
style for his whole career and he's done
it at a pretty high level so i think you
know just some of the things that he's
been able to
really enhance
within our offense has been
you know a lot of fun to watch you saw
like that off schedule play that he made
down in the red zone he made another one
to jake kumaro where you know i didn't
anticipate the ball going where it went
but that's where it went
you know the touchdown so
you know
we never want to take that playmaker
away from them
that's matt lafleur the coach of the
green bay packers talking about his new
quarterback aaron rodgers and the fact
that they want to allow aaron rodgers to
be that playmaker the guy that can make
things happen off schedule when chaos
arrives as it often does after the ball
is snapped shereen we played that
because earlier this week one of the big
stories the mike silver article from
nfl.com and if you're watching on nbcsn
you could see mike silver lurking in the
background there he was in green bay
talking to leflore talking to rogers
about this this pressure point that has
emerged as lafleur called it regarding
the audible thing and the problem is
this
in the matlab floor offense they call
two plays in the huddle
and they pick one or the other at the
line of scrimmage based upon factors
shown by the defense now the quarterback
makes the selection but the quarterback
is told what to select based upon what
he sees so there isn't a whole lot of
freedom there for the quarterback to
make his own decision he knows what he's
supposed to do because the coach tells
him what he should be looking for he
picks one player the other aaron rodgers
in comments to mike silver made it clear
that he believes he should be allowed to
use his 11 years of experience to call
whatever he wants to call essentially
have a broader menu at a minimum
of audibles that you can call it the
line of scrimmage and i tend to believe
that that's what the packers should be
doing
but the question becomes how far do you
go with that how much freedom do you
give him where is the line where you
don't want to let aaron rodgers
essentially be peyton manning where he's
running the offense on the fly based
upon whatever he happens to see or
thinks he sees so this is where the
tension is sharing now i'm a little
surprised that both leflore and rogers
are publicly talking about it i think
this is something they should keep
internal but either way we now know it's
there and it's now something that they
have to resolve at some point between
now and the start of the regular season
or during their first regular season
working together
well thank goodness they've had this
audible thing otherwise we wouldn't have
a whole lot to talk about because
this to me is the biggest story of
probably the last couple of weeks
that we're talking about and i think
everybody's talking about don't say it's
a slow time go and
okay it's not the slow time but you know
there's not many quarterbacks i would
trust to get up to line of scrimmage to
leave wide open
audible decisions
but aaron rodgers is one of them 11
years of experience a couple mvps super
bowl mvp this guy has done it and i
think he's earned that but again it's
matt leflore's team it's matt leflore's
offense how much rain is he going to
give aaron rodgers and this is yet to be
worked out between these two and they've
got to get it worked out or this thing
isn't going to work and
packers are going to be looking either
for a new head coach or moving on for
mary rogers and we certainly don't think
that's going to happen so lefleur is
going to have to make this work with
aaron rodgers to be there long term for
this team to win
and that's the awkward thing about this
shireen rogers is the one with the power
because of his contract because of the
fact that he's the most popular person
in the entire organization an
organization that doesn't have an owner
he's the owner and he's the guy who's
going to call the shots here and what's
amazing to me is
that they hired a coach knowing or at
least they should have known that he was
bringing this system to town i suspect
that during the interview
they they had some conversation about
how the offense would work mark murphy
played in the nfl hey what are we going
to do about audibles how much freedom is
aaron rodgers going to have at the line
of scrimmage to change the play well
mark i'm glad you asked that question
he's not going to have much not freedom
at all and how about we're hiring you
for the job anyway i mean this is
something that can't have caught anyone
by surprise whether it's brian gooda
koontz the gm of the team or mark murphy
the ceo who made that hire and now it's
out there it's out in the open and and
look i i know that there are some out
there who believe that i am quick to
criticize aaron rodgers and those people
may be correct but i i think that it's
fair to say
aaron rodgers taking this pub and i i
understand mike silver was there and he
talked to both guys when you read the
whole article it doesn't look as bad as
the tweet that came out last week but
still
what other quarterback would be engaged
in a public debate with his head coach
about how much freedom he has at the
line of scrimmage i can't think of
another time it's ever happened and here
it is happening in green bay with the
first new head coach that aaron rodgers
has had since he became the starter in
2008.
yeah and the question is where is this
thing headed and how's it going to work
itself out
does it work itself out in training camp
we know aaron rodgers doesn't play much
in the preseason he's going to play
probably more than he has the last
couple of preseasons but is this when
they work it out i don't know that he's
going to get enough work there i think
this is something that aaron rodgers
probably is going to work out in that
first game
when he gets up there and decides he
doesn't like either of the two plays
that were called and changes it up at
the line of scrimmage and
if it works i i think that's probably
the direction they go and if it doesn't
work matt laflore is going to say look
here's the two plays here's what we have
to do but this thing has disaster
written all over it if they can't get
together and decide what they're going
to do going into the season
and here's the other shrine the audible
thing is now a thing so we're going to
be paying attention to it the reporters
who are embedded with the packers will
be paying attention to it and if we
didn't know it was a thing maybe we
wouldn't be paying the kind of attention
we would so now here's what's going to
happen i mean and we hear all the time
coaches don't want distractions well
guess what here's a distraction from
matt lafleur in his first season as a
head coach because you're going to have
reporters looking for any evidence
talking to receivers linemen anyone to
find out whether or not aaron rodgers is
coloring outside the lines that matt
lafleur has put there for him to adhere
to and i think rogers ultimately does
win this one because what are they going
to do bench him for deshawn kaiser no
he's going to be able to do what he
wants to do but now by going public with
it it's become an issue it's been
flagged and we're all going to be paying
attention to this power play that is
going to play out one way or the other
between leflore and aaron rodgers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports